[Noel] Sandi, we've got
-to get back to the future.
-Okay.
But first you've gotta dress
like Marty McFly.
That's pretty much how I dress anyway.
To the car.
Why are we going back to the future?
Is something terrible about to happen?
-Terrible.
-[gasps]
Is Donald Trump getting that peace prize?
-It's worse.
-No.
Are One Direction getting back together?
It's worse than that.
-Oh, no!
-Yeah.
Prue's about to tweet the name
of this year's winner. [gasps]
What are you doing, Prue?
We've got to get back to the future.
[engine revving]
[tyres screech]
[bleating]
[Kim-Joy] It's a really
peaceful, lovely place.
I just wish I felt peaceful inside.
It is very nerve-wracking.
Not as stressful as writing my thesis
but quite there.
[Briony] It's just completely
surreal to be here.
It's the tent, like the actual tent.
[Jon] More people have been in space
than been in that tent.
It's the ultimate.
[Luke] This is like
being a professional footballer
and playing at Wembley in t'FA Cup Final.
[Ruby] It's crazy though.
This is something you've seen on TV
and thinking, actually, this is,
it's quite real.
[Sandi] Twelve new bakers.
I believe that I'm gonna be good
under pressure. Ha.
Very close to a heart attack. Very close.
[Sandi] Thirty brand-new challenges
set by judges Paul Hollywood
and Prue Leith.
I'm really excited to be back.
I know what to expect now.
I will be a bit tougher this year.
I would like to see more imagination,
more colour, and above all,
more delicious things to eat.
Prue and I have set some
pretty awesome challenges.
Some they would have heard of before,
some they definitely have not.
I cannot wait to get started.
I'm quite creative, I love the unusual.
[Imelda] The competitive part of me
wants to see how good I actually am.
Could be out in week one,
who knows. [laughs]
[Dan] I love being a stay at home parent
but sometimes you don't
get to feel successful.
If I can get Star Baker once,
I could leave here very, very happy.
[in French] I'm very excited.
I can't wait to get started
and then we'll see.
Happy. [chuckles]
[theme music playing]
[Sandi] It's biscuit week
and over the next two days,
the bakers will face three challenges,
after which one of them will be
named our first Star Baker
and another will be asked to leave.
[Noel] Hello bakers.
Welcome, for the very first time,
and your first ever Signature challenge.
The judges would love you
to make 24 regional biscuits.
Hilarious, biscuits with funny accents.
Yeah, no, they don't have to speak,
they just have to be traditional
to a town,
village or region in Britain.
They can be sweet or savoury,
you know, depending on their history.
But the biscuits must mean
something to you.
For example, if it was Sandi,
she'd probably choose shortbread.
Yeah, don't start, it's the first day.
Okay, so your biscuits need to be uniform
and identical across the batch
but with your own unique take.
You have two hours.
[both] On your marks, get set, bake.
All right.
Oh, I cannot believe we are here.
Oven, oven, oven. Turn the oven on.
[Paul] This year,
we're kicking off with biscuits.
But don't kid yourselves,
biscuits are difficult to make properly.
In you go.
[Paul] We're asking them to create
something that's a regional speciality.
Something that celebrates
the bakers themselves.
Something that's unique.
The difficult thing for these bakers
is that although we want them
to put their own stamp on this biscuit,
it still must be recognisable.
So, if they tell us it's a shortbread
then it should be melt in the mouth.
If they tell us that
it's a ginger snap, it should snap.
I'm looking for regional perfection.
[Paul] Good morning.
[Briony] Hello.
-Hello, Briony.
-Hi.
You feel nervous?
Yeah, a little bit.
Tell us about your regional biscuit.
I'm making Empire biscuits
which are regional
to Northern Ireland and Scotland,
which is where my family's from.
Um, but I'm giving them a Bristol twist,
which is where I'm from.
It turns out Bristol
doesn't have a regional biscuit.
But now Bristol will have
a regional biscuit.
[Noel] Briony, a full-time mum
to two-year-old Norah and puppy Archie,
took up baking five years ago.
I've got playdough hands.
[Noel] For that Bristol touch,
she's using apple cider jam
instead of traditional raspberry
between her vanilla shortbreads.
And what's that in the pan?
So, I'm boiling some eggs for my,
for my biscuits.
[Paul] Boiled eggs?
[Briony] Just the yolks
which you sieve into the dough itself
and it gives them
a really short structure.
-Have you tried it without...
-Yeah.
Oh, I haven't tried it without,
but well...
So, you don't know the difference?
[Prue] No, but I've never heard of that.
Don't start straight away.
-I'm just asking a question.
-She's just arrived.
It sounds lovely, Briony.
-Thank you very much.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Don't let him do anything to you.
-[laughs]
[Sandi] Like Briony,
most of the bakers are basing
their biscuits on shortbread.
I'm making lemon Shrewsbury.
It's a very rich crumbly biscuit.
This works every time at home.
Like it's never gone wrong
so I don't really know why I'm panicking.
[Sandi] Stay at home dad, Dan,
took up baking to lavish his children,
Barnaby and Constance,
with tasty treats.
Yay! A real fish!
[Sandi] His sandwich biscuit
featuring strawberry jam
is a family favourite.
-Hello.
-How are you?
-I'm all right. I'm all right.
That doesn't sound like you're all right.
No. Sort of, panicking a bit
but you know...
-Is baking your chill time?
-Yeah.
And you've now turned it into a nightmare.
-[laughs]
-Yeah.
[Noel] But you have
entered a competition so...
It is my own fault.
Sort of, your own fault.
[Noel] Our next baker
is using an ingredient
they hope will deliver perfect
melt-in-the-mouth shortbread.
Clotted cream. I love cream, oh yummy.
Mum was like, no, it's too many,
you know, don't eat it.
And then when I came to England
and they were like,
"Oh I'm just gonna spread some cream
on the top of my scone,"
I was like, yeah, this is a thing!
[Noel] Londoner Manon grew up in France
on her family's egg farm
where she began baking aged three.
[in French] Manon, stop eating them!
[Noel] She's bringing Gallic flare
to her Cornish shortbread
with hazelnuts and chocolate.
I'm from Brittany in France
and Cornwall really reminds me of home,
so I had to do it.
[Sandi] For her clotted cream shortbread,
Ruby is ripping up the rule book.
I am making some Masala Chai Devon flats.
I'm using a cream substitute.
I know it goes against
the whole Devon clotted cream business.
I hope that doesn't come and bite me
in the bum because it was fine at home.
[Sandi] As well as knockout bakes,
project manager Ruby,
likes to pack a punch in the ring.
I need a break. Oh.
[Sandi] She's hoping
a killer combo of cardamom,
clove and cinnamon will floor the judges.
What sort of texture are we looking at?
Are they gonna break, crack, crumble?
They will be in between.
Soft, medium. Medium...
You're winging this, aren't you?
How many times have you
actually made this?
They've been soft, medium and hard.
Um, I have practised it a lot actually.
-[Paul] Right.
-I'm not, I'm not winging it, I swear.
[Noel] Whatever texture
they're aiming for...
Want quite a snap on the biscuit.
[Noel] ...overload their dough
with flavours or colours...
Beautiful.
[Noel] ...and it will radically alter
the bite of their finished biscuits.
In India, we have quite a lot
of home-made sweets
with coconut and fennel.
So, I'm just doing a combined,
both of those two flavours in my biscuit
and my mum really like this biscuit.
So, in Calcutta, my family's still there,
and I came to U.K. about seven years ago
to do PhD in Loughborough.
Do I need to get comfortable?
Yeah, I love to talk
as you probably realise.
[Noel] Rahul, a nuclear scientist, Skypes
his mum and dad back home every day.
[in Bengali] You need to cut your hair.
Your beard too.
[in Bengali] No,
I look fat when I shave it!
[Noel] Baking three big biscuits
which will cut into 24,
Rahul's fusing Indian
and Scottish flavours.
There is nothing
that should be overpowering.
You should taste shortbread
but there should be a hint of coconut
and a hint of fennel behind.
And I'm keeping the fennel seeds whole,
so I don't really want to overpower
anything with anything,
I just want everything to go in harmony.
Well, I'm afraid we don't have time
to talk to anybody else now.
It's the end,
it's the end of the show. [laughs]
This is my problem.
When I start talking I don't stop
and that's a problem.
[Imelda] I am making flake meal biscuits
from Ireland.
Traditionally these biscuits
wouldn't have been flavoured at all,
so I have, kind of,
put my own twist on it,
with cherries and white chocolate
and coconut.
[Sandi] Former teacher Imelda,
lives in County Tyrone, Northern Ireland,
with her teenage son, Piers.
Her hearty farmers' biscuit will feature
oats and wholemeal flour.
-That'll keep you regular.
-Yeah, that's...
Never thought about it like that.
I can feel movement happening already.
I've chosen a Yorkshire gingernut
as I'm from Yorkshire so representing.
[Noel] Looking to inject some zip,
Luke's flavouring with lime.
Gives you like a bit of a citrusy vibe.
So, it just, kind of,
works really nice with the ginger.
[Noel] By day he's a civil servant
for the department of education.
By night a DJ on the Sheffield club scene.
To ensure it punches through,
he's adding lime to his biscuits
and his filling.
It's all about that balance
between the ginger and the lime.
I've been doing
a lot of practising at home,
'cause what I want is the lime to come
through first, and a few seconds later,
like the heat of the ginger come through.
Um, so hopefully...
-Look forward to it. Thank you, Luke.
-Thank you.
-All right.
Am I in the light? What's my line?
One hour.
"One hour." What's my motivation?
Perfect. Bakers, you have one hour left.
Cor, it disappears quite quickly,
doesn't it?
-I thought I was good.
-That was excellent.
Okay.
[Kim-Joy] So, I'm just
rolling out my shortbread.
Just making sure it's the same thickness.
[Sandi] Each and every biscuit
should be uniform in shape...
It's good.
[Sandi] And size.
I'm just weighing out each of these balls.
15 grams each.
Wouldn't normally do this at home
but we have to get them identical.
[Noel] But for the five bakers making
sandwich biscuits, it's twice the work.
I'm making 48 cookies like, phew.
I'm really hoping I get that done in time.
[Noel] Bengaluru born Antony is a banker
whose love affair with Bollywood
even influences his baking.
Wow, that's proper spicy.
[Noel] He's sandwiching mango chilli jam
between colourful biscuits.
Hey, we haven't danced.
Isn't now a good moment?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-You go with the hands first.
-Yeah.
-It's the bulb on top.
-Okay.
This leg needs to go up.
Yeah, and then we go down.
And then we go up. Yeah, there you are.
-Okay.
-That's Bollywood.
You are definitely the most fun person.
[Kim-Joy] Just stamping up my shortbread
so they say York,
and then I'm gonna chill this tray.
That goes in the fridge.
[Sandi] Their dough may be resting
but the bakers can't...
Right, where we at?
[Sandi] With decorations
and fillings still to make.
I get requests every year
for strawberry jam.
Hopefully, they'll like it.
Oh chilli, oh the mango.
These Indians know how to do it,
don't they?
[Jon] Just making butterscotch sauce to go
in my Swiss meringue buttercream.
I'm baking an Aberffraw biscuit.
I want to go for something Welsh
for the first week, being as I'm Welsh.
[Noel] Jon's love of baking is matched
only by his passion for sailing
with his children and wife Debbie.
[ship horn blaring]
He's updating the 13th-century
Aberffraw of a butterscotch filling
to satisfy his sweet tooth.
Too sweet, it's like being too
good-looking I find, you know?
Hmm, lush.
[Kim-Joy] So, this is just a glaze.
I'm gonna also add
a bit of orange blossom.
[Sandi] Kim-Joy's also flavouring
with a personal favourite,
she discovered in the bath.
I bought a hair conditioner
and it smelt really nice.
And I looked at what's in it
and it had orange blossom.
So, I thought yeah, that's like
a piece of me in my biscuit.
[Sandi] A mental health specialist
working with students,
Kim-Joy's a huge fan of oriental flavours.
Her orange blossom York biscuit
will be topped with the county's
emblematic white rose.
[Noel] These look beautiful.
Sort of getting the urge
to call you Lovejoy, is that okay?
Lovejoy? Oh, is that like a flower?
-[laughs]
-No, it's not.
-Detective?
-It's an antiques dealer.
[laughs] He's like a sort... It's, it's,
-I've heard of Lovejoy.
-It doesn't matter. How old are you?
About 12? You won't know who he is.
[Noel] Our next baker's
also decorating with white roses.
Oh, gently, gently.
[Noel] But she's making hers from scratch.
They take longer than you think.
But obviously, for this challenge,
I thought perhaps
I ought to have a little go.
[Noel] Grandmother Karen
works part-time...
Strawberry, young man?
[Noel] ...as a product promoter
at a local supermarket.
Juicy?
[Noel] She's basing her biscuits
on a traditional Yorkshire Perkin.
[Noel] So, are you a Yorkshire lass?
[Karen] I am. Wakefield.
-Wakefield.
-Shaky Wakey.
[both laughing]
You're looking very Elvis-fied.
[Noel] Elvis slash Shakin' Stevens.
Or as Sandi says, KD Lang.
[Sandi] Our final baker's topping
his biscuits with mini works of art.
I'm gonna try and recreate
24 identical little lambs.
Terry
[bleating]
[Sandi] When he's not painting
or sculpting,
keen artist, Terry,
takes to the great outdoors.
Walk on, walk on.
Walk on, Amy.
[Sandi] His shortbread will feature
oatmeal topped with chocolate decorations.
I'll make chocolate wafers.
The lambs hopefully...
Oh, it's a lamb?
[Sandi] I think
it's 'cause it's upside down.
Hopefully, they'll be tidied up
from this but... [laughs]
Right, I'll get them in the oven now.
[Sandi] Perfecting 24 identical biscuits
with a single oven...
This is next one.
[Sandi] Will require this year's bakers
to navigate a timing
and temperature minefield.
[Terry] First ten in.
We're off, we're off.
These are going in the oven
for eight minutes.
[Noel] Misjudge either across
any of their batches...
23 minutes at 165 degrees.
[Noel] ...and they can kiss goodbye
to even textures and colours.
Yeah, I just need to rush a bit
because it takes 40 minutes to bake.
I'll put six minutes on the clock
and hope for the best.
[Manon] I can't keep my eyes off them
because I'm just like,
don't get too brown.
Don't really want any colour
on them. Look.
The back ones are a little bit
more brown than the front
so I'll probably leave them
in a little bit longer.
I think they need four more minutes.
I'm looking for a wee bit
of browning on them.
They're looking a bit pale.
I'm not panicked just yet.
Soon but not yet.
Bakers, you have
just half an hour.
I do radio as well as television,
you know.
Waiting for my first load to come out
the oven then put my second load in.
Yeah, they look good.
Nice golden brown colour.
Beautiful. Happy with that.
Yep, I think they're done.
Mixed results on that one.
There's a few duds.
So that's batch one done.
Second lot in.
They just jumped off the tray.
Now I'm just adding the jam to make sure
that the paisley sticks on.
[frustrated grunt] Fudge.
I think I need to speed up a little bit.
It is hot in here.
[Terry] Chocolate's not good in this heat.
It's not setting quickly.
Ooh!
Just piping around the flowers.
[Imelda] Decoration has to be so uniform.
You just have to be better
than one other person, don't you?
[Dan] They look so pretty though.
It would be a shame
if one of them fell on the floor.
Uh... [laughs]
Okay, how long have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Sweet baby Jesus.
[Rahul] Oh my God.
I am so running behind on time.
Finished. 24 biscuits.
[Terry] Definitely last-minute dash.
I've not got one decorated biscuit yet.
Would you like a crisp?
I would like nothing that involves
taking my eyes off this table.
[Briony] Don't want to rush it too much
'cause they're already
spreading a little bit.
I don't want to make them look messy.
They're not set. [sighs]
I am making some masala chai tea
and it works really well with the biscuit.
[Terry] Come on. Come on, release.
Chocolate in this weather.
I shouldn't have done it.
[Rahul] I am rushing the decoration.
[Manon] Do you want me
to help you put them on?
-Thank you, yeah.
-Cool.
Right, shall we do this one, yeah?
How many have I got?
One, two, three, four...
-Eight.
-Ten, eighteen.
How many do I need, 24?
This is ridiculous.
They don't even look like lambs.
Just one more.
They're still melting.
Bakers, your time is up.
Yes!
Boom!
Please put your biscuits
at the end of your benches.
[blows raspberry]
Done!
[Terry] I'm going out.
Hey, this is one of three.
-This is one of three.
-I know.
We've done it. Yes.
[crunching]
[exhales]
[Noel] The bakers now
face the judgement of Paul and Prue
for the very first time.
-Hello, Antony.
-Hello, you guys.
Fascinating looking biscuit.
Those colours are incredible.
Brilliant, they are quite psychedelic.
Love that.
[Prue] I think they look like little
modern art, they're so pretty.
[Noel] Prue, you just like them
'cause they match your outfit.
You know what? That texture is beautiful.
Melts in your mouth.
And that chilli jam blends
gorgeously with it.
-Thank you, Paul.
-That's a, that's a great biscuit.
Boom!
-I'll take that.
-Absolutely. Simply wonderful.
I have to take one away with me.
Yes.
Well done.
[Paul] I think your piping work
is beautiful. It does look amazing.
[Prue] Nice and spicy. Very chewy.
I don't like the texture.
It's like a very, very small cookie.
It didn't blow me away.
Well, I'll take a lot back
from that anyway. That's it.
They are absolutely exquisite.
-Aw!
-I just love them.
[Paul] Beautifully balanced biscuit,
you break into it and then it instantly
starts to melt in your mouth
and the beautiful flavours come out.
There's enough acidity from the orange
to make your mouth water.
Well done.
[Paul] It looks quite pale.
I do think it is a tiny bit under baked.
It's quite bland.
It is down to the bake,
it needs another three, four minutes.
Cheers.
First of all, they are extremely neat.
I like the look of them.
[Prue] Ooh, very nice.
[Paul] The biscuit is beautifully baked.
It melts in the mouth, it's buttery.
I love chocolate and I love hazelnut,
so you just ticked two boxes there for me.
That's a fantastic biscuit.
[Manon] Thank you.
Would be nice with a glass of milk too.
-Well, it's there.
-Well done.
-Thank you very much.
-[Prue] Good.
-Thank you.
[Noel] I like this,
it's like owl feathers.
-But it has a lot of flavours in it.
-[Rahul] Yeah, it has.
I don't think the fennel
has quite the punch you thought it has.
-Okay. Yeah.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[Paul] The reason why you've got 25?
I'm bad at maths.
Do you know, they taste a bit dry.
[Paul] It's like a dried sponge
rather than a biscuit.
It's very difficult to eat.
Okay. Do you want to taste the tea, Paul?
Yeah, that's wet. They're dry.
Great. Phew.
[Paul] They are quite pale looking.
That is tough.
Is it?
[Prue] It's a bit chewy.
[Paul] That's not a shortbread.
It needed longer in the oven.
The flavours are great.
And that jam's delicious.
Just don't like eating it?
Everything else terrible. Thank you.
[Paul] Hello, Terry.
[Terry] Hello, Paul.
Right, okay, this is interesting. Um...
Not my finest hour.
The lamb is not good, is it?
Love it, it's like a Warhol print.
Yeah. I don't like the colour,
I don't like the look of them.
They are not neat enough for me.
Yeah.
[Paul] Right.
They are a little bit hard. Great flavour.
It's just that, you know,
the execution is a bit of a mess.
[laughing]
It's a rough old biscuit, that one.
Never mind.
-Thank you, Terry, thank you.
-Live to fight another day perhaps.
Onwards and upwards indeed, thank you.
You can do it.
You can be the comeback kid,
you can be the comeback kid.
Let's hope so, Noel.
[Paul] I think they look great.
They look like a proper gingernut.
Hmm, ginger's lovely. Just right.
The lime, however, it just isn't there.
It does need a bit more lime. Nice though.
You can breathe now.
[Paul] They look very neat.
[Imelda] I'm scared.
-[Paul] Break well.
-Okay.
That's a delicious biscuit.
Very oaty.
-Yeah, feels healthy. Well done.
-No, it's not.
-Thank you.
-But it is worth the calories.
Absolutely. [laughs]
[exhales]
[Paul] Hi, Briony.
[Briony] Hello.
-Looks good.
-Thank you.
And they are pretty uniform
in colour and size.
They're very neat.
I certainly like the scalloped edges.
I think that looks beautiful.
Right.
The shortbread is really
melt-in-the-mouth and crumbly.
What do you think about the egg yolk?
I think it's probably the best shortbread
here today.
-I'm gonna try.
-Oh good.
[Paul] It's a crumbly, soft,
buttery biscuit
and then that bite
which comes from the apple,
the cider, and the caramelisation
on the top, the sweetness,
it just blows your mind.
It's a great biscuit, that.
-Oh, thank you.
-Well done.
Really good.
Oh, I'm shaking.
Pretty overwhelmed actually.
And for Prue to say
she's then gonna use a yolk technique...
[laughs] Oh my gosh, wow.
[Terry] Not in the place
I would have like to have been.
Wrong biscuit, wrong day.
Paul said it was beautifully baked.
Okay, it's a good start.
It's my whole school life.
Could have done better really.
I mean, I thought biscuits
were meant to be dry?
[Sandi] The bakers were able
to practise their first challenge.
[inhales]
Every week their second will be a mystery
shrouded in gingham.
[exhales]
Hello, lovely bakers,
it's time for your first
Technical challenge
which today has been set for you
by the lovely Paul.
This was a real favourite of mine
when I was a kid.
Please don't mess it up.
As usual, the challenge is judged blind,
so Paul and Prue are not
going to be lingering in the tent.
Okay, off you two go. Thank you very much.
What are they up to today?
Bouncy castle.
Ah that's nice.
-For your Technical challenge,
-[all laughing]
Paul would like you to make his version
of the iconic Wagon Wheel.
[Noel] You have to make eight
and you have two and a quarter hours,
so you have to get your wagons rolling.
On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
[Karen] Ooph! Well, that was unexpected.
Do not panic.
[Noel] The iconic
wheel-shaped chocolate biscuit
was launched in Britain 70 years ago.
I do know what a Wagon Wheel is. Hurrah.
Have I made one before? No. [laughs]
I have absolutely no clue what these are.
[Noel] To make them, the bakers
have all been given the same ingredients
from Paul's pared down recipe.
I've never made a Wagon Wheel in my life.
But, yeah, I love 'em, so let's go for it.
So, Paul,
this is the first Technical challenge.
Why have we got Wagon Wheels?
I think there's mainly different elements
to a Wagon Wheel.
It's quite tricky.
You've got that biscuit which is crunchy,
it's about getting the marshmallow right.
Not something that's rubbery,
not something that pours out
and then the chocolate coating must be
nice and even over the top.
[Prue] The chocolate should be firm enough
to hold that marshmallow.
It's really beautiful.
The difficulty is putting
all that together without panicking.
You've got to test 'em.
For the biscuits, tip the flour,
salt and butter into a bowl.
Takes me back to my teacher days
where I'm like,
read the question, underline
what they're looking for. [laughs]
I did okay at exams.
So, cool as a cucumber.
Rub the butter into the flour...
I made a few mistakes this morning
so I'm hoping to not do that again,
especially in the Technical as well.
The first Technicals always
gonna be a tricky one.
Stir the sugar, vanilla paste,
add the egg yolk...
I did something wrong already.
I didn't rub the butter into the flour.
But we just got to go on with it.
[Sandi] Have you made these before?
I've eaten lots of them before,
never made them.
There's a few people here
who've never even heard of them,
so you're ahead of the game.
I've never had one.
-Really?
-No.
-You've never had a Wagon Wheel?
-No, darling.
What? Have you even lived?
No Wagon Wheels?
Uh, I, I'll be honest with you.
I was 55 before I tried a Pot Noodle.
-Well... Well, what can you...
-Yeah. It's possible
-You can't come back from that.
-I missed out. I've missed out.
Okay, so what do I do now?
Bring the dough together.
[Luke] It's important not to,
sort of, knead it.
You'll lose that shortness in it.
Not mess with it too much.
Just need to get the jam on now.
Raspberries. In you go.
Add the sugar and bring to the boil.
The jam you want it,
you want to get some heat in there.
Look at that jam. Cooking away,
bubbling up to thicken a little bit.
It's not looking how I would like it
to look. It seems a little watery.
Right, what's next?
Bit that scares me about this
is the marshmallow.
Tip the sugar into a medium pan,
add the glucose, the water...
[Rahul] I've never made
marshmallow before.
Still, I'm hoping that... Yeah, we'll see.
Look at me? It's gonna be great.
See look at that. Huh? Is that working?
Well, no.
As soon as the sugar syrup
reaches 120 degrees, remove from the heat.
A little off there yet.
I need it to cook but it isn't.
My sugar isn't cooking.
[Karen] So, there we are you see.
It's starting to get syrupy
I'm just following the recipe
and it's going okay.
[Antony] You've got to be kidding me.
I did something stupidly wrong, yeah.
I just need water.
Whisk the egg white in the bowl
of the stand mixer until firm.
Pour the sugar syrup over the egg whites.
You want to pour it down the side
and it magically
turns into fluffy marshmallow.
Well, that's what's
hopefully gonna happen.
Ah, pretty good.
Happy with the marshmallow.
Bakers, that is one hour gone.
On a lightly floured surface,
roll out the biscuit dough.
Cut out 16,
7-centimetre circles from the dough.
Well, they were much larger in my day
and then they got smaller.
You were smaller.
And now they're smaller... Yeah,
that's probably you're probably right.
You were small, it looked big.
The whole world still looks big to me.
I wish I was still small,
things would look bigger and then...
You're like a giant amongst men to me.
Ah, thank you.
Well, no, it just says, and then bake.
Going in, guys.
On 160 for I don't know how long.
Let's say 12 minutes.
I'll keep a little beady eye on those.
I am really back in time.
Come on, biscuits.
I see them gently cooking. [chuckles]
That's going in. I'm falling behind now,
I need to run, run, run, run, run.
Okay, I think I'm gonna take them out.
Looks pretty good.
They're looking tanned.
They are cooked and they're circular.
[Imelda] Just gonna need them
to chill a bit
before I put the chocolate on them.
'Cause otherwise
the chocolate will just slide off.
[Terry] The chocolate, again, is my worry.
Having the disaster this morning
with chocolate.
[Noel] Why you doing that?
I'm just trying to like
cool the chocolate a little.
It's because you're French, isn't it?
You like to sort of...
No, no.
It's the French way of stirring.
The English people are all doing this.
To assemble,
spread some of the melted chocolate
over the base of eight of the biscuits.
Just trying to make them
as beautiful as possible.
Trying to get a nice smooth finish on it.
My hands are starting to shake.
Right, just get those in the freezer.
Bakers, you have
30 biscuit baking minutes left.
Come on, come on.
Pipe the marshmallow
over the remaining eight biscuits.
[Ruby] Try not to pipe
too close to the edge
because I know when they sandwich
I don't want, like, serious spillage.
Oh dear. Marshmallow's overset.
My piping bag's split
because it's so thick.
All right. I need to assemble.
[Imelda] It's been a while since I've had
a Wagon Wheel, so I can't remember
how much jam is in them.
[Dan] Sandwich the biscuits together.
Coat the biscuits
with the remaining chocolate.
-It's quite vague innit, this?
-Yeah.
-You know why, don't you?
-Yeah?
-Paul.
-I know he's a so-and-so.
He don't give much away.
I'm trying to figure
how to do full coverage.
This is the stage I'm really unsure about.
Just gonna do it like this.
Dear, dear, dear. It's gonna be shabby.
[Ruby] I'm gonna go for a full coverage.
Cannot get the chocolate to come around
the side. So annoying.
[Manon] I think they're coated
all the way through.
[Karen] Just doesn't
want to flood that gap.
Desperate measures.
[Antony] I need this to be
a sprint finish.
All covered, perfect.
Put them in the freezer
I think just to chill quickly.
Gives those a couple of minutes
and see how we get on.
[Imelda] It's not doing it for me.
[Antony] Disaster.
[exhales]
How long we got to go?
Bakers, you have one minute.
What!
[Sandi] Run, run like the wind.
[Imelda] Oh, sugar plum fairies.
Proper disaster.
[Imelda] Horrendous.
Right, bakers, that's it, your time is up.
Boom, first Technical done.
[exhales]
Please bring your Wagon Wheels
to the gingham table
and place them behind your own visage.
[Noel] Paul and Prue are expecting
eight identical Wagon Wheels
with two crunchy biscuits
sandwiching fluffy marshmallow
and tart raspberry jam
coated in smooth chocolate.
And they'll have no idea whose is whose.
-Right, shall we start over here, Prue?
-Okay.
-They are all coated.
[Paul] Let's have a look inside.
-[Prue] It's rather good.
-Actually, it's pretty good.
[Paul] The biscuit's
got a bit of crunch to it.
The marshmallow's silky
and they're all equal.
Moving on, now these haven't quite set
and obviously,
there was an issue because the chocolate's
not gonna bond with the bottom.
It was a time question.
If we left it,
they'd be glued to the plate.
[Paul] Okay, what has happened?
Big rush job, this one.
I'm not sure that counts as a Wagon Wheel.
I think this is also
going to be a timing issue.
[Paul] It's totally
detached from the bottom.
[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] Moving on, it's neat,
biscuit's nice and crunchy,
nice depth of biscuit.
Good taste. Good texture.
That's very good.
[Paul] It's a bit rough but it is set.
It's been spread
rather than poured or dipped.
Oh, the marshmallow's good.
[Paul] We wanted the sides covered.
I think it's probably
a bit too much marshmallow. [laughs]
That's what happens
if you don't cover the chocolate.
These are very good. Nice and smooth.
[Prue] I think this is the best-looking
we've seen.
[Paul] Holds together well.
Nice and tart, the jam,
smooth marshmallow.
Very good.
Okay.
[Paul] There's a lot of chocolate on that.
-[Prue] Is this for a chocoholic?
-Wow!
[Noel] If you were a kid
you'd be delighted.
I am quite delighted.
Okay.
[Paul] They are set.
Very little marshmallow.
Feels quite rubbery.
Right, never sealed up
the marshmallow around the side.
[Prue] Not quite set.
This is the messiest job.
[Noel] This is not a job.
[all laughing]
[Prue] This one looks good.
[Paul] Got almost that Wagon Wheel
look to it on the top.
Cuts well, biscuit nice and deep.
Nice thick layer of marshmallow.
That is really clever.
[Paul] It's very good.
[Noel] Prue and Paul
have made their decision.
In 12th, we have this one.
Who's that? Antony.
It wasn't finished,
no coating on the edge. Disaster.
In 11th position, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Bit of a rush and you ran out of time.
[Sandi] Kim-Joy is 10th,
Terry 9th, Luke 8th,
Rahul 7th, Karen 6th,
Jon 5th and Dan is 4th.
In third position, we have this one.
Whose is this? Very well done.
Have you seen these before?
Chocolate's excellent, nice and smooth.
Yeah, I think it's a great job.
-Thank you.
In second position, we have this one.
Who was that?
Briony, they are absolutely delicious,
they're the right thickness.
They're a really good Wagon Wheel.
Thank you.
So, in first position, we have this one.
Lovely shine on the chocolate,
nice and smooth,
marshmallow is good,
that's a nice Wagon Wheel, well done.
Thank God. I was feeling pretty rubbish
this morning,
so, yeah, really happy about that.
[Imelda] It was such a high
at the start of the day
and now, second to last,
that's pretty crap.
[Terry] A little deflated.
Tomorrow, I need to pull back something
from a disastrous day.
[Manon] Really lucky, I had no idea what
was a Wheelie Wagon. What is it called?
Wagon Wheel? Wagon Wheel.
[Sandi] One challenge remains
before someone
is crowned this week's Star Baker
and another becomes the first
to leave the tent.
Morning, bakers. Welcome to your
very first Showstopper challenge.
Today, Prue and Paul would like you
to make a spectacular
biscuit selfie portrait.
Honestly, not words I ever thought I'd say
in the same sentence.
Your selfie should be constructed
from layers
of decorated biscuits
and sandwiched together
with fillings of your choice.
Your portrait needs to be of you,
somewhere memorable.
You've got four hours to complete
your Showstopper challenge.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Right.
[Sandi] This Showstopper
is a fiendish test
of our bakers' biscuit making ability.
Not only must they engineer
a giant biscuit canvas
but also make multiple intricate elements
to bring their portraits to life.
[Prue] This is the first opportunity
these bakers have had
of showing us artistry,
skill, imagination.
We want the selfie to be built up
with layers of biscuits
because we want some depth to it.
[Paul] We want a proper portrait
displayed on an easel,
so obviously the biscuit sliding
is the big problem.
They could use caramel,
they could use royal icing.
They are the perfect things
to bond the biscuit
and withstand the force of gravity.
Importantly, we don't want
style over substance.
If they don't taste like the most
beautiful biscuits you've ever eaten,
they're not gonna get anywhere.
It is a monumental challenge.
[Imelda] A lot of time pressure, and
after falling victim to that yesterday,
I don't want to be
in the same position today.
[Terry] I need to be
at the top of my game.
Famous last words.
[Noel] As well as a dough
that results in biscuits
sturdy enough to construct
a 3D work of art...
My biscuit dough
is a bit of a shortbread texture
but it's got to be a little bit firmer
because it's got to hold it up.
[Noel] ...it must also
deliver exquisite flavours.
[Jon] I'm making
a cinnamon and orange biscuit.
I really like cinnamon and orange,
they go well together
and I wish I hadn't done so many oranges.
This is really hurting my arm now.
[Noel] Featuring a lemon curd sun
and buttercream choppy seas,
Jon's selfie was inspired
by a family sailing trip.
We had a lovely placid journey
over to Tenby.
Force six storm in the middle of it.
I thought
it was idyllic sailing conditions
but my wife thought otherwise.
Hence, coming back on the train.
[Sandi] Back on dry land...
My biscuit selfie is,
what a shocker, me in Bristol.
[Sandi] Briony will showcase
her hometown's landmarks
in lemon and poppy seed biscuit.
[Sandi] You've practised it?
Yes, I did it in like
four and a half hours
but that was with my daughter
and my dog around, so I think...
It's the same thing you've got me, Prue...
I'm the dog.
-Good luck, Briony.
-Thank you very much, thank you.
If I'm gonna be your dog,
what kind of dog have you got?
A Cockapoo.
A Cockapoo. Okay.
I'm a method actor, so I need to know.
[laughs]
[Noel] For his selfie,
Rahul's heading down memory lane.
First time when I came to U.K.
I went for a walk,
it was lovely, everything was green,
flowers were coming out.
So, this is basically on that memory.
[Noel] To recreate
his springtime stroll in gingerbread,
he's got a detailed blueprint.
[Rahul] These are the trees
and the canal and a bridge
and then it's me.
I got about 23 pieces.
It is very, very ambitious design.
[Sandi] But with a triple-layered
40 biscuit design,
Ruby's taking ambitious to the next level.
My portrait is me,
finishing the London marathon.
[Sandi] Decorated with numerous toppings,
her marathon selfie
involves a marathon to do list.
[Ruby] I'm not gonna tell them this,
I have never finished it in time.
I've never even finished it.
Let's hope that's not the case today.
I am just rolling out my dough,
starting with the, the base biscuits
because they take the longest to cook.
[Antony] Okay, let's go.
[Noel] Getting the giant biscuit canvas
baked early is critical.
So, I've done four of these squares.
That's gonna like be the background
and everything's gonna be stuck to that.
[Sandi] The longer it takes,
the less precious oven time they'll have
for their smaller biscuits.
This is a cherry blossom trees.
They are my glasses
[Jon] These are the waves.
[Sandi] Just come to check on you.
[Jon] Just very sweaty at the moment
You were sweaty yesterday.
Is that like a thing for you?
-Yeah, very.
-Mr. Sweaty?
I'm always Mr. Sweaty.
I don't know if that makes me
more attracted or less?
I'm gonna go with less I think, Jon.
Stand next to me,
you'll always look less sweaty.
Ah, there's so many pieces. Shattered.
I love the mountains,
so I climbed Kilimanjaro.
The selfie itself
is right on top of the peak.
[Sandi] Antony's ascent of Africa's
highest mountain will be realised
with royal icing and biscuits
flavoured with local spices.
Ginger and cinnamon,
you will get that bang on
as soon as you put a cookie in your mouth.
[Noel] Like Antony, half the bakers
are basing their selfies on trips abroad.
It's certainly my favourite place
which is in France.
We've got a holiday home there.
[Noel] Karen's doubling down
with two flavours
that often divide opinion.
[Prue] Rosewater and cardamom together?
Yes. I can see the eyes rolling.
No, I absolutely think
that is a wonderful flavour combination,
I really do, as long as the rosewater
isn't overpowering.
Well, this is the trouble, isn't it?
-It's all a balance. Good luck.
-Thank you.
I'm gonna moonwalk away from you now.
See ya.
This is gonna be Palm Springs.
Me and my husband actually had our kids,
uh, with the help of a surrogate
in California.
So, we stayed in Palm Springs for a month
just getting to know our kids
and it was just amazing.
It just was the best moment in my life,
so don't tell my husband that.
[Sandi] Dan's journey into fatherhood
featuring his firstborn
will be made with almond sugar cookies.
When it's all decorated with royal icing,
it's gonna be me holding a baby.
[Noel] Luke's also heading stateside
but his trip was strictly adults only.
[Luke] I went to Las Vegas
with my friends a few years ago.
We basically
went on a bit of a mad night out.
The inspiration, that's where
it came from,
a bit of a drunken night out
with my friends on holiday in Vegas.
[Noel] He'll be flavouring
his biscuit sin city
with orange zest and cinnamon.
For some reason, I associate cinnamon
with America, so I thought I'd try
and keep the flavours, sort of,
paying homage to America, if you like.
Going in.
Pop these in for eight minutes.
[Karen] Those are my little eyeballs.
Bye-bye,
and good luck.
[Rahul] Those are all the glacier mints.
They should melt in the oven,
so it's gonna create glass bits.
Stressed.
Just feel like I won't have enough time.
But maybe I'm panicking, I don't know.
Buttercream next.
I'm making the royal icing.
This is just gonna make
a right old royal mess.
Gin time, it's gin o'clock.
[Terry] This is my flour buttercream.
This should be like a thick custard.
It's just not right.
Oh, scramble your eggs in your lemon curd.
I'm gonna try and salvage it.
So, we have some matcha
which is like Japanese green tea.
I went to Japan last year,
so this is a picture of me
in front of the Mount Fuji.
[Sandi] Not only with Manon
use matcha ganache
to bond her biscuits
but also to decorate them.
[Manon] I just want to carry on
what I've started
and just finish on a good day.
Hmm, yep. Good.
[Sandi] She's not the only one taken
with the land of the rising sun.
[Kim-Joy] It's a portrait of me
at Miyajima shrine in Japan.
[laughs] I was there at sunset,
it was really peaceful.
[Sandi] To offset her tranquil backdrop,
Kim-Joy is flavouring
with a trio of punchy spices.
[Kim-Joy] The ginger tends to come through
a bit more than the cinnamon.
It's quite strong on ginger, I hope.
Got to time call. Time call, time call.
We've got to time call.
Bakers, we're halfway through.
Okay, your serve.
-[alarm dings]
-Is that my alarm?
[Ruby] See these babies are coming out.
That bad boy's going in.
They still look pretty anaemic.
Yesterday, I slightly
under-baked my biscuits,
so I'll risk them being a little brown
just to make sure
that they're definitely baked.
[Sandi] To add depth to their selfies,
most bakers are making robust biscuits
which they'll layer on top of each other.
Yeah, they're looking good actually.
[Sandi] Terry is taking
a very different approach.
We're doing a brandy snap biscuit,
um, I'm using it because of its qualities
as a mouldable material.
When it comes out of the oven
it's still quite liquid
but you have got a very small window
to play with it.
This is just a three-dimensional
surgical plaster face cast.
It will cool very quickly
when it hits the mould.
[Noel] After a disappointing first day
in the tent,
Terry's summoning
all his artistic talents.
[Paul] So, you're using the brandy snap
as your main feature
and then the background,
you're using what exactly?
-It will all be brandy snap...
-Yeah.
...laminated with raspberry jam
and flour buttercream,
mixed into three primary colours,
and then I'll just paint a picture.
Sit and do what I do well.
[Imelda] I am not arty at all.
I'm hoping I'll be able to argue
with Prue and Paul,
yeah, it actually does look like me.
[Sandi] Imelda's celebrating a fun day
out in Mayo
with lemon and ginger biscuit.
It's an opportune moment for you
to come along.
I know, how's it going, how's it going?
-Horrendous. Look at it. It's burnt.
-Oh, really what, what?
No, darling it just looks, um, colourful.
Not the look I was going for.
I'm stressed.
[Sandi] One hour to go.
Oh, dear, dear, dear, dear.
We are way behind.
Right, let's make some magic.
I am sticking backboard biscuits
to the backboard.
This is just like royal icing
to glue the big biscuit.
[Luke] And then there's gonna be
other biscuits
which are raised on the other biscuits.
So, building, building it.
[Imelda] This is my mountain,
it's overbaked.
I just hope I can decorate it enough
so that they don't realise.
Oh. Oh, my goodness.
But you know Paul and Prue,
they're gonna know.
They'll know to look at it.
Oh, that one's gone.
[Ruby] Just working on the buttercream.
I need to start assembling. I am late.
[Kim-Joy] I am using caramel
because I think it'll be a firm bond.
I just hope it just stays together now.
[Jon] I've got a lot of worries
about this slipping.
If I had a couple of days for it to set
I'd be a lot happier.
[Ruby] Looking around, people are making
some decent progress.
I think I've shot myself
in the foot a little bit.
Way too over-adventurous.
If I get this done
it's gonna be an absolute miracle.
So, this is a matcha ganache.
So, the buttercream
is gonna become like the sky
and the mountains and some foliage.
It's so time-consuming
'cause there's so much biscuit to ice.
[Briony] Some bits are a bit
scruffier than I'd want.
[Sandi] Can I have
a piece of your biscuit?
-I know what you're gonna say.
-[groans and grunts]
You're choking right? Took your tooth out?
Yep. No. It's delicious.
[Kim-Joy] I'm about to do the sky.
I'm doing it like a painting basically.
I'm like a mad artist
when I get to this bit.
It's different every single time.
I think it depends on my mood.
[alarm beeping]
Oh, I've had some severe breakages.
[in frustration] Oh.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
I think the next thing to do
is get me on the board.
I can start my painting now.
[Rahul] Just make my skin colour.
I've got my large hooter there
which I've always been very proud of.
Ah, I look like the joker.
Stop panicking, stop panicking.
Wow, look at you.
You look a bit like Bjork in that picture.
That's alright.
You do have a bit of a Bjorkness to you,
-has anyone ever said that?
-Do I?
No, someone told me I look like
Michael McIntyre once, though.
[laughing]
[Ruby] All my biscuits are cut out now
but doing my marshmallow fondant
is a real messy business.
[groans] Oh. Oh my God.
[Imelda] This looks like horrendous mess
but I'm hoping it's gonna come together.
[exhales]
I'm starting to panic
like I've got some sort of shake on.
[Rahul] This is like a grassy bit.
Here's me holding a baby. My hands!
[sighs]
That's beautiful.
[Noel] Hey, Ruby. You okay?
I'm losing it, Noel.
Oh no, you look a bit frantic.
The pieces coming now.
Oh, no, it's cracking.
Bakers, you have one minute,
just one minute.
[sighs]
Fondant.
Hideous.
[gasps] Burst pipe.
Oh Rubes.
[Sandi] Bakers, your time is up.
Dear God.
[Sandi] That's the end
of your Showstopper challenge.
[exhales] Oh, my goodness.
Please put your selfies
at the end of your workstations.
I just ran seriously out of time.
They are gonna judge it on biscuit, right?
[Manon] Yeah.
-[sighs]
-What are you holding?
[Dan] A baby.
Oh, I thought it was something else.
[Noel] It's judgement time
for the Showstopping selfies.
Dan, please bring up your biscuit selfie.
[Paul] Artistically it's great,
colourful, three-dimensional.
I question the baby though.
It looks like a massive prawn.
[all laughing]
[Prue] I think the colours are fantastic.
The palm trees are definitely
swaying in the wind.
You can feel the heat.
Certainly get the passion fruit.
I get the almond in there as well.
It's delicious, the blend between the two.
It's a nice biscuit.
-The biscuit is excellent.
-Phew.
You've done a great job.
[Prue] I think it's amazing.
You can see immediately it's sunset
I think you've done a really great job.
The colours are really well-balanced.
Could do with a tiny bit more spice.
-I thought so, yes.
-But it's very nice.
It has a Vegas feel about it.
I love the depth.
[Paul] It's, it's not very often you get
cinnamon and orange together
-and it works.
-[exhales]
I think the biscuits a bit under baked.
[Paul] The biscuit is a bit soft.
Very neat, very precise.
You can see it's you.
Well, it's certainly gingerbread.
You've got a gorgeous balance
between the cinnamon and the ginger.
Really good.
There's some lumpy lemon curd there.
Yeah, it went slightly wrong.
-Lumpy sun.
-Got a little bit overcooked.
The flavours are absolutely lovely.
[Paul] I love that chocolate
with that orange and cinnamon
and that biscuit is spectacular.
Rahul, would you like to bring up
your biscuit selfie, please?
Well, you've certainly succeeded
with this explosion of the English spring,
and I'm fascinated by your portrait.
[Paul] Where's the stubble on the face?
Oh, that was like seven and a half
years ago.
I was clean shaved at that time.
So, I'm taking it back.
[all laughing]
[Prue] I think
it's definitely recognisable.
Nice and short, isn't it?
Hmm.
[Paul] The ginger comes through
beautifully in a well-baked biscuit.
That, with the design that you've done,
even your little chubby face,
it's fantastic.
I think you've done a great job.
[Sandi and Noel] Well done.
Thank you. Thanks a lot, cheers.
You look like a cross
between Dame Edna and Sue Pollard.
That's been said a few times.
-[Paul] Oh really? Oh right.
-Yes.
Can't get the rosewater.
Really?
[Paul] You get the cardamom
a little bit but very...
You definitely can't get the rosewater.
Got scared with the bottle
and obviously didn't put enough in.
[Paul] It's a shame 'cause it looks great
but you expect a little bit more
kick to it, you know.
A bit more oomph to it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[Prue] It's quite simple.
I'm trying to recognise you
in that picture.
I suppose you could say, yeah, it is.
[Prue] You can't eat her.
He's just going to chop your head off now.
Paul, it looked like
you enjoyed that a bit too much.
The biscuit's a little bland,
quite thick
and a little dry.
It's a bit like a stale shortbread.
You get the lemon, you say ginger as well?
Definitely not getting the ginger.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
[sighs]
I can see what you were trying to do.
-Yeah, was too, too ambitious.
-I think it was too much.
[Prue] All that work has meant
-that you didn't finish yourself.
-Yeah.
And this is supposed to be a selfie
and it's supposed to be recognisable
and I don't think it quite is.
[Paul] Okay, let's try this biscuit now.
-Its cinnamon and ginger.
-Yeah.
It's a strange taste of ginger.
You, you do get the cinnamon
and it's almost like they are fighting
each other for supremacy.
-Right.
-The biscuit's a bit soft.
A little bit dry.
-[Prue] It's not the best ginger biscuit
-Oh, you guys.
I've ever eaten.
It's a shame you didn't finish it.
Yeah. Brutal.
[sighs]
Love the colours on it
and your portrait really works as well.
I love the balloons, can we eat a balloon?
Yeah, please do.
[Prue] Nice thin icing. I like that.
I would like to have
had more flavour in there.
Okay.
It's a nice biscuit,
just needed more of a punch.
Okay.
That's good.
Excellent.
Thank you.
So detailed and so neat.
It's just exquisite.
I was nervous that the matcha
would be overpowering
but it's not at all, it's just a hint.
Wow.
The biscuit is delicious
but the balance of flavours and textures,
I think you've done,
I think you've done an amazing job.
-Thank you.
-Well done.
-Thank you, Manon.
-Really good.
Terry, please bring up
your biscuit selfie.
Ingenious.
[Prue] I think your face is brilliant.
I've got chocolate, brandy snap,
buttercream and jam.
It's absolutely delicious.
Lovely.
[Paul] It's quite tricky to work
with brandy snap in that sort of size
but to manage to get that
3D mould of your face,
and then the colour in there as well,
I think the whole thing is very clever.
-Well done, Terry.
-Thank you, Paul.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
Well done, Terry.
[Terry] The comments were much better
than I would have hoped for, to be honest,
um, or expected.
If I've done enough,
it's a scrape through.
That's two pretty poor bakes.
[exhales]
Even though I've done my best,
I feel like I've just let myself down.
[Ruby] I feel like I'm just
back at the bottom again.
I'm just hoping that they can kind of see
that whatever happens,
this week was just first week nerves.
I'm... Yeah,
hoping for a bit of a miracle.
[Sandi] Paul and Prue must now decide
who'll be our Star Baker
and who will be the first
to leave the tent.
What a fantastic dozen we've got.
Aren't they amazing?
Feel like we got to know them
quicker this time.
Maybe that's just because we've got
their portraits in front of us?
-I don't know.
-[laughing]
So, who's rising towards the top?
Manon. The style of her baking,
it's very classically French in many ways.
Everything's precision.
It's just completely wonderful.
I think Briony's really
impressed me this weekend.
A proper solid Showstopper.
She's definitely in line
for Star Baker as well.
And who's struggling?
Coming into today, Terry was in trouble.
And then he, sort of,
pulled a rabbit out of a hat, didn't he?
Pulled it off. That brandy snap
was like an impressionist painting.
Has he done enough to save himself
over the three challenges,
not just the one?
Imelda, she struggled in the Technical.
Terrible Technical.
[Paul] I think today
the biscuit wasn't good.
I think she had a lot to prove,
I think the pressure got to her.
[Prue] Ruby, first in the Technical
but her other two were really not good.
This one she didn't finish.
[Sandi] I think what's astonishing
is we've just met these twelve
and I would already be sorry
to lose any of them.
-I know.
-No, agreed.
Now, I have the pleasure of announcing
the first Star Baker.
The Star Baker who had
a wonderfully nutty first round
and whose attention to detail
was unbelievable.
The Star Baker is Manon.
Thank you.
So that means it falls to me
to deliver the sad news.
The person going home is...
Imelda.
[all] Aw.
[Sandi] I'm so sorry.
Great job.
Oh God.
Okay, okay.
-Yes.
-You all right?
I am sorry.
That must have been like the tightest call
ever. I'm so sorry.
Frustrated, because I know
I can do better.
But at the same time,
one of the best experiences of my life.
I'm sorry, Prue, I can do
so much better than that.
I feel really bad
because part of me feels like
it probably should have been me.
-You were very lucky.
-I know, I know.
But I'm like completely relieved.
Terry, well done.
Week one done.
Kick up the backside I guess,
and so I've got to pull my socks up.
-Yes!
-We're through to next week!
It's been the most awesome,
intense, terrifying,
wonderful weekend and I'm really excited
that I get to do it again.
-Excellent work, excellent.
-Thank you. Thank you very much.
More of the same, please.
[speaks French]
[man responds in French on phone]
[in French] I won the first episode.
[man in French] You won the first episode!
[laughs]
[Luke] Congratulations.
[Manon] A dream start.
We will see what comes next.